the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
so this is josh and john they're both
from Planet nutshell josh is the founder
and John is an animator yes and they're
going to talk today about storyboarding
and continuing our discussion on visual
storytelling I'm super excited about
today's session is going to be a lot of
not only lecture but workshopping some
of the scripts and ideas that you guys
have been thinking about so far Oh
Josh's background is in creative writing
so you can also get feedback from him on
your scripts and they make short
explainer videos that engage people not
only in assimilating information but
entertaining them as well yeah so we and
in a lot of ways do many of the things
that I mean I guess directly that you
guys are working on so this is a good
fit for us to be talking to you so yeah
so my job is to sort of rally all of the
people who work at Planet nutshell in
interesting creative directions and john
is a really talented illustrator and
animator and he also does our storyboard
artwork so today after I give a brief
little talk about animation and
storyboarding we're just I'd really like
to just open things up and share with
you a script that we produced a while
ago and we'll all storyboard it together
and I would love to see what we come up
with we've produced this script but
what's really great about what we do is
there's no one right way to do it so
what will be interesting is to see what
we come up with collectively here as
opposed to what we produced and I have
looked at your scripts the things that
you're working on they're all really
interesting so I would like to open
things up to any questions you have
about what you're working on
a little later and yet I write a lot of
scripts so if you need help with that
I'm very willing to give you any
guidance I can so I'll get started with
the this short lecture portion and John
I think now or somebody made this
spinning thing for you guys today we
thought that would be a nice touch ding
all right let's see yeah so we're going
to talk about animation and
storyboarding and specifically animation
in the context of what you guys were
doing I mean animation is a huge topic
and I'm not going to go I'm not going to
talk about you know techniques or or
theory or any of that kind of stuff but
I do want to talk about when it's a good
idea to use it maybe in your own work
and there may be more reasons why it
might be good but these are the ones
that i came up with four today so
animation is good when synthesizing
reinforcing or recapping information in
a simple visual way cows + farts equals
global warming so taking abstract ideas
or or summarizing information and
presenting it very simply is something
that animation is really good at so when
thinking about developing your own
scripts you can think about moments
where the visual story could be
augmented with some sort of
encapsulation or summary that that is it
is worthy of animation and here's a
here's one that's pretty obvious the
subject cannot be seen it's microscopic
cosmic or theoretical and abstract so
those are often good times to think
about animation and we have some
examples of where this sort of thing is
employed later John came up with this
one actually John helped with all these
because I was really busy this week but
so I really appreciate it footage is not
easily attainable so say you want to do
a video about well in your case you know
you're doing naval naval engineering
maybe you want to shoot you know
something about like the bottom of the
ship you know or you know something that
is going to be real you're going to have
to hire a team of scuba divers to get
down there and shoot the hull of this
ship so that might be a nice a nice
opportunity for visualization that can't
be attained through lab action and this
kind of the catch-all category is that
animation adds visual engagement the
story is somehow made better by using it
and that that's sort of an abstract sort
of subjective thing to say but I think
the best way to demonstrate that is just
to show examples which I'll do in a bit
so animation is sort of silly or not a
great choice when it's and I and I we
use this term a lot like is this eye
candy or is this really a functional
part of the story you know and again is
it eye candy or is the story made better
so just using animation because it's
cool or it's neat can actually distance
the viewer from and disengage them from
the experience because I don't know if
you guys watch you know you see in a
movie like the Transformers or oh god
what are some of these ridiculously
visually opulent movies you know and a
lot of times when I watch those sorts of
things i began to emotionally disengage
from them because all I'm doing is being
bombarded by visual information there's
no story that's really compelling or
engaging me so that's something to think
about live action is really great at a
number of things and these are some of
the things I came up with the notion of
personality the human face the human
experience
the host as as Elizabeth talked about on
Monday location creating you know
there's an its animation can create a
lot of interesting locations but you
know there's why would you draw the MIT
campus when you when you're when you
have it right in front of you for
instance and again the notion of human
interaction you know humans talking to
each other and engaging with each other
is a really is something that live
action is really good at or in the final
catch-all category is you just can't
think of anything better to do so oh I'm
just going to animate that part I
haven't really I don't really want to
think about how I'm going to present
this so I'm just going to do some
animation and that's not the best choice
you should be making choices based on
what the strengths of animation are in
the strength of live action yeah choice
to make and the one that happens most
often or the one that happened most
often when we were making seasons one
and two is that we'd hit a point in the
script that looked a little bit complex
in terms of visual execution and
say well what are you going to do here
and the host or the cast would say oh
well we're just we're just going to
animate it and as if like that was going
to solve all the problems and I think
that these points may sound like sound
pretty reasonable and obvious but it is
very very hard to thoughtfully integrate
that into your visual script so I really
encourage you guys to think about
especially the third point not
defaulting to animation because you
don't want to figure out their visually
integrate your script into the video
yeah okay so here are some examples of
videos that integrate both live action
and animation there are many examples I
thought these were especially strong
ones you'll note that the composition I
don't know what you guys you can talk
you're going to talk more about how you
made this one but the composition of
this one works is it was obviously
designed around position you know
position of the live-action character
and the animated elements I have seen
this story of stuff series it's quite
interesting yeah I'll play a little bit
of it so next the mature
during one of these i got a little
obsessed with mine in fact i got a
little obsessed with all my stuff have
you ever wondered where all the stuff we
bike comes from and where it goes when
we throw it out I couldn't stop
wondering about that so I looked it up
and what the textbook said is that stuff
moves through a system from extraction
to production to distribution to
consumption to disposal all together
it's called the materials economy well I
looked into it a little bit more in fact
I spent 10 years traveling the world
tracking where our stuff comes from and
where it goes you know what I found out
that is not the whole story there is a
lot missing from this explanation for
one thing this system looks like it's
fine no problem but the truth is it's a
system in crisis just a storytelling
component there that I really like is
you may already sort of know is that we
talked about it on Monday like here's a
paradigm or here's a situation that you
probably already understand but hang on
there's a problem there's more
complexity here than you ever could have
imagined and I'm going to tell you about
it and that is like a really cool
storytelling component on top of the
integration of animation and live-action
and the reason it's a system in crisis
is it's a linear system and we live on a
finite planet and you cannot run a
linear system on a finite planet
indefinitely every step along the way
this system is interacting with the real
world in real life it's not happening on
a blank white page it's interacting with
societies cultures economies the
environment and all along the way it's
bumping up against limits limits we
don't see here because the diagram is
incomplete so let's go back through
let's fill in some of the blanks and see
what's missing well one of the most
important things that's missing is
people yes people people live and work
all along this system and some people in
this system Matt
a little more than others some have a
little more say okay so you get the idea
I mean it's a long video but it I think
it retains engagement because of the
quality of the writing and because of
the interest that's created from the
artwork I encourage you to watch the
whole thing to get a chance let's see
okay cool this is a sign you mind if I
play some of this or have you guys
already seen this video or okay I'll
just play the beginning and this says
George in it who I assume you saw
yesterday you know what's more like life
than a box of chocolates parts you
really never know what you're gonna get
gunk rotten eggs garbage dumpster the
possibilities are unfortunately endless
but why do we fart and how does your
buddy make so many different smells the
answer is fermentation this is a giant
bioreactor it's also called a fermenter
in in here a fungus note
brewer's yeast is transforming water and
dead plants to beer
so you know that thing where you eat
food and breathe in oxygen to get your
energy that's called respiration yeast
also need to get energy from food but
there's no oxygen in those tanks so they
have to use a different process called
fermentation now both your cells and
youth cells break food down to get
energy but your main byproducts are
carbon dioxide and water and yeast main
byproducts are carbon dioxide and
alcohol that's how this stuff gets to be
beer okay I think that similar concept
integration of animation and live-action
in the way that the animation somehow
augments or improves your understanding
of what he's talking about let's see so
let's switch back here so that's a very
brief overview of how you can use
animation in your own work how to do it
technically and artistically is another
matter I'm happy to talk about that you
know separately I don't know how much
training is going in this course for
animation but oh you have the equipment
if you want to learn more like we have
about 10 of these similar tablets if you
guys are interested
and running about this but we're not
going to go to super in-depth yeah this
might be an opportunity for you to talk
about that segment that you did and from
what I understand your the animation
that you do is fairly rudimentary and
very effective and it might be something
that these guys could pull off all right
so I'm going to talk a little bit about
one of the scenes from the farts video
and this was actually something that
George was going to talk about yesterday
and his script writing workshop so this
will tie in pretty nicely if I can get
this to work
alright so take a second to read this
passage
so when we were writing the fart script
this was a piece of information that
George had come across which he found
very fascinating it was one of the sort
of shareable facts that he latched on to
the fact that the microbial population
in your gut is about ten times greater
than all the somatic germ cells in your
body now if he had said this line in the
video it would have been a disaster
right but what is this passage
essentially saying does anyone want to
take a guess not just that so somatic
and germ cells basically refers to all
of your human cells
there's more stuff that's not you in you
yeah yeah basically so right right so
the way George decided to distill this
down is that there are 10 times as many
microbes living in your gut as there are
human cells in your body I mean that's
basically what this entire passage
taking from taken from a journal article
is saying but the problem with saying
just this is that at least for me and
for George one of the questions that we
thought of as an audience member was
well how does that exactly work like how
can you fit ten times as many bacteria
in you yet you're not walking around
just like oozing bacterial cells like
completely outside of your body because
I think a misconception that people
often have is that they're the same size
right so it was kind of this paradox
that wasn't essential to the story of
the video to explain yet was a potential
point of confusion so this was a reason
why we decided to use an animation in
this particular spot because as Josh was
saying earlier we felt like the story
needed to be clarified we felt like the
story needed to be advanced a little bit
but we also felt like if we took the
time to say there are ten times as many
microbes in your gut as there are human
cells in your body which doesn't make
sense because you would think that you'd
be oozing out bacteria but it actually
is fine because bacteria are a lot
smaller than human cells right that
actually is like two or three seconds of
very very precious time wasted and sort
of loses the momentum of the video so we
decided to do an animation to explain
all of that instead so what we did was
we had shot everything without the
animations and our storyboarding process
is incredibly genki but it essentially
works and hopefully after today your
storyboards will be a lot better than
the one we used but what I literally did
was I got the rough cut of the video and
I got all the footage and I specifically
was looking at this portion of the video
where this animation would need to go
and I took screenshots of the video at
various time points where I knew the
animation
need to go so and this is setting the
line in context of the section that he
was delivering so the first line was
turns out we carry a fermenter right
here with us in our gut and this was the
still that he had said that so I was
telling the editor at this point I want
a fermenter to show up and he actually
motions during during the the scene and
then there's the second line except
instead of use my gut uses gut bacteria
so I was trying to convey to the editor
to take my drawing of the yeast and swap
it out for a drawing of a bacteria again
this is like incredibly rudimentary you
don't have to be an amazing artist to
pull off the clarity that you need for a
storyboard and then he says a lot of
them and I wanted a ton of bacteria to
show up and then we get to the line
there are 10 times as many gut bacteria
as there are human cells in your body at
which point i wanted lots of bacteria to
show up and then show it in comparison
to the human cell this was going to be
the key frame to explain the concept of
how you can have so many bacteria
without losing it outside of your body
so essentially where we were explaining
the whole difference in scale through
one frame this reminds me a bit of that
the flipping cat video we saw on Monday
and there's a segment in that video that
I think is kind of weak where he is
explaining a lot of technical
information and yet in your mind you're
just not I just didn't absorb it I
couldn't follow it and I was thinking
you know this would have been a lot
better if he if he may be done some
better script writing but also maybe
some animation you know I think
animation can be really good at moments
like these when when you've got the
sophisticate or complex information and
you need you need to make it you need to
maintain engagement with the viewer but
also encapsulate it yeah you know so
yeah anyway sorry to hijack yeah yeah
and then the the whole reason why we are
the whole way we wrap up that scene is
he explains that instead of just one
species of
like they use when you brew beer that's
the whole reason why we were at the
brewery my gut uses hundreds and if we
just had that text I think that it would
bring up a lot of questions or maybe
points of clarification for the viewer
that again we just didn't have the time
to explain in the script which is why we
relied on the animation to do it for us
so there John's going to show you some
animations that are awesome and very
artistic for our animations I literally
just take a sharpie and a piece of paper
and I draw out the doodles thank you um
but it's not as nothing crazy um and I
basically scanned them in to our editor
and had named each picture and then in
the storyboard I had explained okay
here's my drawing of the fermentor
please refer to ferment or JPEG for the
image I want you to use and then he went
into After Effects and inverted all of
the drawings and move them around and I
think you're going to talk about after
effects just a little bit we can talk
about after effects okay and again if
you want to play with any of this on
your own there are really good tutorials
on Linda calm and as MIT students you
guys have free access to the entire
library so if you want a tutorial on how
to use after effects which you all have
access to as well if you're interested
you can just come talk to me during
class so we we storyboarded everything
out and then I do the doodles and the
keyframe here was this picture that sort
of explains the whole concept of how so
many bacteria can fit inside of you but
it just takes one picture instead of ten
words and so this is what the that scene
ended up looking like weird turns out we
all carry a fermenter with us right here
in our gut except instead of yeast my
gut uses bacteria and a lot of them
there are ten times as many bacteria in
line
as there are human cells in my entire
body and instead of just one species my
god uses I got used two hundred sorry
got cut off and so I mean there are many
ways that we could have done that like
Joshua saying there's no right way when
it comes to animations when it comes to
video in general but this was sort of
our way of working around the problem of
not having access to the footage of real
bacteria necessarily it was just the
world that we couldn't access or didn't
have time to access or would have been
too distracting to access in this video
the other thing I wanted to mention
really quickly before Josh continues is
when we shot we shot knowing that we
were going to do the animation overlay
in mind you may not know that ahead of
time so what I would suggest if you're
interested in doing something like this
is to shoot thinking that you're not
going to do an animation overlay and
then just do another take just in case
you want to do something like this so
the way we framed the shot we tried to
make sure that the background was dark
enough to where the animations could
appear this is not an ideal framing and
not an ideal background so I'm sorry to
use this as an example this is probably
one that we could have improved but i'll
show you another one these small
molecules are called metabolites just
like how all the DNA an organism forms
the genome all of the metabolites formed
amitava loan even though each metabolite
can be made from only six elements there
are so many possibilities that it would
take scientists thousands of years to
make each one and figure out and figure
out its usefulness so we have the exact
same storyboarding process to create
this but when we shot Anastasia that day
I knew that this is what I wanted to do
for that scene so we told her to go like
this with her hand and we were like
we're going to put stuff there don't
worry and we framed her wide enough we
gave her enough grass space outside of
her that we could fit some of these
animations and so just anticipating that
and I can talk more about this tomorrow
when i talk about producing is a good
thing to do if you want to do animations
and i'll show you one last those animals
get
by slightly bigger animals which get
eaten by slightly bigger animals which
get eaten by animals at the top of the
food chain animals like us so that's the
raw footage from our video on
engineering river cleanups and again
this is a spot that we knew we wanted to
do an animation there so we framed her
in such a way that there was enough
background space to accommodate for the
animation and we actually told her ok
we're going to put fish along here in
post so pretend like you're looking at
stuff point to them as if they're going
to be fished there eventually I think we
also did it take where we just had her
delivering it normally so we had her
framed with not as much extra space
behind her just in case we weren't going
to use that animation but again sort of
anticipating using that if you need it
so this is what the final scene looked
like those animals get eaten by slightly
bigger animals which get eaten by
slightly bigger animals which get eaten
by animals at the top of the food chain
animals like us so again it wasn't
incredibly vital to have these
animations one of the reasons why we did
use it is that in the context of the
video which I'm going to show tomorrow
we felt like the visual interest was
getting a little bit static so we used
animation to move the story forward in
that we felt like it was getting a
little visually monotonous by the time
this hit and the other thing is the food
web stuff is okay to explain i think
that if you didn't have the animation
it'd still be okay but it just added i
guess a little moment of whimsy to it
and so that was sort of our
justification of putting it there so i
just wanted to show you guys those
examples and josh you can continue on
okay
John when when John is doing some is
helping us out with the work shopping
portion we can he can show you some
projects and after effects I don't think
after effects is it is very kits it's a
complex program with a lot of capability
but I think some basic compositing like
this is would be quite easy in it so
when we can we can show you some of the
those just some basics about after
effects
you